demi lovato set a sexy thirst trap for
henry cavill and at work the real story
behind Tiffany Haddish his selfie with
Beyonce Plus young Simba JD McQuarrie is
in the house fresh off his amazing
Grammys performance hello my love's we
got through the longest month ever and
it is finally February 1st which means
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner
and if you're unlucky and love like me
let's take a cue from Demi Lovato and
what may or may not be strategic online
flirting Demi was caught by some
stealthy Instagram users following
Superman himself and REE cavil but not
before she liked two of his jujitsu
photos and posted this very sexy shot of
herself now this is what zeroing in on a
target looks like my friends and guess
what it worked
Henry then followed Demi back and
commented on one of her own jujitsu
pictures this is awesome nice one miss
Lovato and that is how it's done
sliding into the DMS apparently is so
2017 it's time to thirst and bait like
Demi and 2018 alright another woman who
goes after what she wants
Tiffany Haddish and what she wanted was
a photo with Beyonce you'll remember the
girls trip star snapped this rare selfie
with the queen bee and now we have the
back story behind the moment and it's
kind of crane Tiffany told vulture that
the photo op came after Beyonce talked
her out of getting into a fight at the
same party they were at quote I'm not at
liberty to say what had went down at the
party she was like no have fun Tiffany
and I said I'm only gonna have fun if
you take a selfie with me well
Beyonce agreed but their interaction
didn't stop there no Tiffany says after
Beyonce buried her face in Tiffany's wig
Bea told her her way was slipping so
good looking at Beyonce
now the comedian was just happy to be
recognized by Beyonce quote she knew who
I was she came up to me and was like I
think you're so funny Tiffany Haddish I
was like what you know me she said I'm
Beyonce I know and thank you for letting
me read and not that can I get an
applause
appreciate it thanks guys I'm fishing
I've got it alright moving on to
somebody who hasn't met Beyonce yet but
will very soon her young Lion King
co-star JD McQuarrie now you might not
know his name just yet but trust me you
will the 10 year old is playing young
Simba in the live-action movie and he's
also the singing sensation who nearly
stole the show at the Grammys performing
with childish gambino a moment that as I
found out was a walk in the park for the
young
how'd it feel being up there sharing the
stage with Donald Glover and also
performing in front of that kind of
crowd oh that was just awesome I'm just
so glad that everybody supported me and
everybody like turned out with a good
reaction and I really think Donald
Glover childish gambino because he's the
best
were there any nerves right before the
performance no I just felt really
confident no surprise there JD says he's
been singing since he was two the
California native recently showed off
his chops on Ellen
[Music]
and how's this for the circle of life
JD will reunite with his Grammys pal
Donald Glover in the Lion King live
adaptation as young Simba
what was your reaction when you got the
part I was so stoked up that's just so
amazing like I freaked out yeah cuz I'm
on a Disney movie I am one of those
people that's right that's crazy
the thing that I'm most looking forward
to is just seeing everybody's reaction
and I want I want to react to it
cuz I only got a little preview I'm not
gonna spoil it for you guys but it's
amazing it's ending up it will have to
wait until july 2019 to see it for now
you can catch JD on Tyler Perry's the
pains on own and of course be on the
lookout for more music how would you sum
up what's been going on with you in your
life these last couple of years oh yo
that kid is amazing and he told me he's
hopefully gonna be putting out an album
eventually but doesn't want to rush the
process he said all right guys this
weekend is the Super Bowl and tomorrow
I'm taking you behind the scenes of
Justin Timberlake's halftime show
performance so hit subscribe and I'll
see you then